Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for our 26th episode!
And you know,
End of another week.
Right!
We did it!
Well, for Ruffians who are joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Ruffians.
If you could please do us a favor and tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FUWAMOCO Morning.
FWMCMORNING.
That'll make us happy, right, Moco-chan?
BAU BAU!
Let's all start our brand new day with a big BAU BAU to FUWAMOCO Morning!
Let's all start a brand new day with a BAU BAU to FUWAMOCO Morning! BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians.
Did any of you see Pero by any chance?
I think we had another Pero Sighting.
De-den!
Oh, it's still summer.
We spotted Pero at a very unique looking indoor pool.
I guess you know Pero probably doesn't want the summer to end either, right?
Yeah, a local pool like that pool is good for that, right?
Right.
It makes sense.
No, that still kind of sounds good to us, too.
Just, you know, the bathing suit part.
Maybe not so much, but... I wonder, you know, Ruffians, do you think that Peron's maybe planning on going for a swim?
Or maybe, maybe just sunbathing?
But, but... If he wants to sunbathe, you usually need oil for that, right?
Maybe he just wants to become a marshmallow.
Pero... A charcoal marshmallow.
That sounds good because you don't need to put the oil on your hands and... He's just... It's bones and marshmallow fluff.
That's not happening.
We're not gonna do that.
But you know, maybe he's just a... swimming or knowing Pero maybe... dare to enjoy the sights of cute bikini girls?
I don't know.
Maybe he doesn't want to swim now.
If that's the case, maybe he doesn't have any intention of doing that.
If you're going to the pool, do proper pool things, you know?
Yeah.
Ruffians, did you enjoy the summer at the pool?
Maybe not.
If you're gonna go to the pool, please do pool things.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, let us know if you see Pero around, okay?
You can let us know with the hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Next!
Ruffians!
We have some exciting news, right?
You know what?
Not today.
Tomorrow!
It's Rin-senpai's 3D showcase!
BAU BAU!
We're really hyped.
If you didn't know, we're very hyped.
It's gonna be crazy, Ruffians!
We're hoping to see Bae-senpai show off her dance skills a lot.
Especially to her original songs, too.
Yeah, you know, the Psycho-Lite Connect world was really, really cool, so I'm looking forward to that.
Seeing more, that would be nice.
You know, I'm a silly antics, too.
Can't wait.
Ruffians, what are you looking forward to?
Any ideas or any... You remember now, right?
Yeah, play dice too!
Right!
I wanna see play dice.
I wonder what the choreography would be like for that too.
Have to look forward to it!
No matter what, it's going to be very cute!
Congratulations Bijou-pai!
Let's all look forward to it, okay Ruffians?
Very soon, very soon, very soon!
But that's not it for exciting news happening tomorrow, right?
There's also... Nobisa!
Nobisa has a new cover song coming out, and this time, it's Dekonina's Vampire!
It's gonna be premiering on Nobisa's channel, of course, at 5PM PT and 9AM GST.
Imagine if it was on FUWAMOCO's channel, huh?
That would definitely make sense, right?
Nerissa's been doing an amazing job with all her cover songs.
She's been knocking it out of the park.
I'm really excited to see how Vampire will be done this time.
Yeah, and this time it's going to be in English, right?
Yeah, we really love, love me, love me, love me.
We really loved, love me.
We did.
We love, love me, love me, love me.
Love, love, love, love.
I can't wait what it's going to be like this time.
I wonder how it will sound in English.
With Nerissa's vocals.
It sounds good.
I'm sure.
Don't tell Nerissa.
We can't wait to hear Nerissa!
Ruffians, have you heard of Vampire before?
You've heard it before, right?
I imagine.
Right.
Well, I think the song's playfulness will really suit her voice, too.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians...
We have a bit of a confession.
A bit of a confession.
We noticed that you noticed.
Something funny.
On Twitter?
I don't know.
I feel like the Ruffians don't notice much sometimes.
Especially when we asked you last FUWAMOCO Morning if you noticed anything particularly funny about our Twitter.
Nothing's funny, ever.
Some Ruffians mentioned it too.
Yeah, so we thought that it might be good to confess about this.
You know?
There's no weird feelings, right?
Just honesty, right?
Yeah, well, you know, there was, there was this thing.
This thing?
Yeah, welcome fest, welcome fest!
It's about who liked
It's really cute!
It's Choco-sensei-senpai in a bunny outfit!
It's cute!
I don't know what the Ruffians got.
It's like a speeding car.
Well, you know, Ruffians, it can't really help but like it.
I'm going.
Speeding car.
At first, you know,
FUWAMOCO Morning!
But meanwhile, Moco-chan on the other hand, you happened to see it and what did you do?
I liked it!
I made the call.
I only found out that we had liked it once the Ruffians started mentioning it.
I was so surprised!
The proper little sister thing.
That's the story.
That's a confession.
You can't blame us, right, Ruffians?
It's hard not to give in to Choco-sensei-senpai's cute charms, right?
I thought you were gonna say it's hard not to give in to Choco-sensei-senpai!
No!
Her charms, you know?
Understandable.
Thank you.
That's how Twitter usually goes for us.
So don't misunderstand that only one of us ever does one thing on Twitter, okay?
It's always a group effort.
We're a team.
We're FUWAMOCO, okay?
Face up this time.
Do you feel lighter now?
Maybe.
BAU BAU!
You know, I feel like we've had enough happy news today.
No!
It doesn't end!
I don't know!
We have more happy news, Ruffians!
Wow.
Do Ruffians want more happy news?
Yeah!
It's the end of the week, it's Friday, we can have lots of happy news.
Okay.
Well, Ruffians, it's not only Friday, but it's the end of the month already.
Can you believe it?
Do you know what this means?
That means... It's been two months since we debuted!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Two months already!
Yeah... It doesn't feel like it, huh?
You know, we thought that we'd like to celebrate a little and be able to show our appreciation for you being here with us for the past two months.
So we thought we'd do another... Roar and Response on Twitter!
We did it last month, but...
And this time, we're gonna be holding it today!
Today!
After I stream from 9.30pm PT or 1.30pm JST.
Today, we're doing YMS VICE's lip-hair battle!
Let's do it!
And we'll be responding to your tweets as fast as our paws can type for one hour and a half.
It's completely random, okay?
So we won't be able to respond to every Ruffian, but please know that we are reading your tweets just like normal, okay?
And you know, last time we had over 1,600 responses.
Thank you!
We did our absolute best to respond, and what time we had...
It's a bit difficult sometimes.
Ruffians, how fast do your paws type?
I don't think you should be that impressed.
To be able to participate is not hard.
Please respond to our tweet about the live response that we're gonna make this time.
And this time we'd like to ask
Something a little bit new.
Please use the hashtag #FUWAMOCO in your tweet, in your response.
It's okay.
There'll be a lot, uh, not a lot, but there'll be information, so don't worry if you don't catch it all right now.
We're looking forward to being able to chat over Twitter, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Don't worry about tapings though.
The only person that needs to be worried about that is us, our people.
People, not person.
We're gonna do our best to write as fast as we can, right Moco-chan?
It was a bit of a panic last time.
But it was really fun, so... We wanna do it again to just feel the show, our feelings, our things, you know?
Let's have lots of fun on Twitter!
BAU BAU!
Well...
You know, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format show, so already we're gonna find out.
Do you have a Doggie of the Day today, Moco-chan?
My Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
Little Mishka!
Don't think Mishka's little?
Mishka looks very, very strong.
Strong?
Well, you know, just like these Ruffians told us, Mishka can really, really have a lot of energy.
We can definitely see that.
Yeah, I think Mishka could run very, very fast.
Faster than me.
I was gonna say that it looks like she might just fly away.
Right!
Like she has some wings on her.
The tail is one wing at least.
Right?
That's what I was thinking!
Little Mishka.
Mini Mishka.
I feel like, you know, with all this energy I'd be like, kind of unendingly
Really annoying in a good way, you know?
Annoying in a good way.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
We'll be good, maybe.
Maybe.
Maybe not.
I think little Mishku, you know, really loves to have fun, but you know what?
She only loves fun because it's fun being with you.
Thank you for keeping this Ruffian smile protected for us.
Let's make this a team effort, okay?
Team effort, okay.
We'll do our best to help her on those really tough days, too.
BAU BAU!
Wow.
Do we have any Ruffians going for a walk?
We have!
It's getting colder so I can understand, but... De-den!
This is such a good photo!
There's a Japanese word you want to teach us?
This is what you call yoemachizuki.
That's so cool.
It's a full moon just the night before it's truly full.
I was noticing it recently, the moon.
It's big.
It's so pretty.
Right!
Oh.
I know that beautiful Japanese word that doesn't quite have a one-to-one meaning in English.
Kind of the commodity, right?
Yeah.
Right, the commodity?
Thank you for the beautiful photo.
We're going for a walk even at night time when it's a little bit spooky, but please don't get lost, okay?
How did you take that photo, though?
BAU BAU!
Nice photo!
Don't howl!
Control yourself!
Drink!
You're better than that.
Well, do we have a question for today?
Our Question of the Day is... De-den!
Hi, FUWAMOCO!
Now that we have a few days into autumn in the northern hemisphere, I've been thinking about fall activities.
Do you two have any favorite fall activities?
Or maybe fun fall memories to share?
Well, you know, it's really starting to get nice and autumn-like here in the Northwest Passage, too!
It's nice.
It's wonderful.
It smells good.
Good air.
Crisp air, the leaves, and the flavors of autumn too.
You can smell them.
Yeah.
But I think, you know, we just, we like to go for a walk.
Yeah!
Especially when it's sunny out.
It's nice to just enjoy the nature and the sights of this season changing.
Maybe you know, go on a walk and enjoy it with a warm drink too.
If you're feeling fancy.
For a fancy day.
But as for the specific activities,
I don't know if this counts, but we often, we like to help Mama Puppy and Popo Puppy out by cleaning up, like, the leaves from the leaves that have fallen off the trees, you know?
And you know, sometimes I like to jump into the leaf piles, because, you know, it's fun, initially.
But then, once you're in there, then you're reminded of all the bugs and the spiders and the wet leaves and the dirt and junk that's in there with you, too.
I feel like it's fun in theory, but maybe not so fun in actuality.
I always tell Moco-chan, Moco-chan, don't jump in there, you're not gonna like it.
But I feel like it!
I feel like it.
And then once I'm in there, it's like, oh no, I gotta get out of here.
I don't know.
I think it's better, you know, focus on cleaning up the leaves.
Don't make a mess, don't get dirty.
I can jump into your leaves.
Just make sure there's no spiders.
You can get them all up and then I'll make them go everywhere.
Just enjoying the fall.
It's nice.
It's cozy.
Getting bundled up a little bit.
Let's all enjoy the fall warmth together, okay?
BAU BAU!
We have a stream tonight too!
Our next stream is... We're going back to the hololive servers in Minecraft!
Along with all of Advent!
Second time.
Technically a third time.
But!
Yes, we're going to work harder to build our base, right?
Yeah.
I'm excited, but I don't know.
We're also still really, really super beginners in Minecraft, so I'm not too sure what it takes to build things yet.
I mean, we kind of helped build a little bit.
It didn't really do much, though.
We did our best.
Yeah.
Ruffians, please show us how things work, okay?
Yeah, and thank you for all the tips on Twitter, too!
BAU BAU!
I really want to be able to understand Minecraft a little bit more.
It seems so fun, but I guess there's a lot to learn, huh?
Little by little, little steps, little steps.
A bit overwhelming, but we'll get it.
BAU BAU!
And let's take a peek at our schedule.
Right before Bae-senpai's 3D showcase, we'll be playing Fall Guys with you Ruffians!
It's doggy time!
Please make sure you download Fall Guys, which you can do for free, and get ready to join us for some silly games.
It's okay if you're not very good, if you've never played before, because let's just have fun together, okay?
And we hope to be able to play with as many Ruffians as possible, so maybe if you're able to get into one game, then do your best!
We'll see you next time!
We like kind Ruffians.
I have a feeling though that there might be some Ruffians who are pro Fall Geysers.
What?
They're pros at it.
They're pro Fall Geysers.
Okay.
We'll do our best too.
Yeah.
We're gonna do it!
We're gonna do our best!
Maybe we might try to play a little bit cheeky.
Not dirty, cheeky.
I'm looking forward to it!
BAU BAU!
Today's FUWAMOCO Morning comes to a close, but that just means a new exciting weekend has started!
Thank you, Ruffians, for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Confidogu!
BAU BAU BAU!
Cablevision.
BAU BAU!
Night owl.
Lettuces.
BAU BAU!
Space toast.
M-type.
BAU BAU!
Slime.
Nobekubo.
BAU BAU!
Poemaru.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!